voilà je vous propose de commencer
par avance toutes nos excuses pour plus
que le quart d'heure ça fait presque 40
minutes
donc d'attente pour vous on en est navré
bien évidemment on vous remercie d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation donc on
continue donc nos travaux de notre
commission d'enquête en vous recevant
aujourd'hui tous les deux donc monsieur
Guillaume dolquès vous êtes ingénieur en
énergie et en environnement vous avez
travaillé dans le domaine de l'industrie
avant de rejoindre l'Institut de
l'économie pour le climat en 2020 où
vous avez étudié l'efficacité des aides
à la rénovation énergétique et les
enjeux d'accélération de l'adaptation au
changement climatique vous êtes
notamment l'auteur de plusieurs études
climat portant sur la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments
monsieur le dez vous êtes chargé de
recherche à l'Institut donc de
l'économie pour le climat dans les
domaines de l'investissement et du
financement public depuis 2018 vous
travaillez notamment sur le panorama des
financements pour le climat dont
l'édition 2022 a été publiée en octobre
dernier
l'Institut pour l'économie l'Institut de
l'économie pour le climat a récemment
publié deux études sur la rénovation
énergétique l'une qui porte sur les
aides à la rénovation et leur
inadéquation aux objectifs de rénovation
globale et l'autre qui porte sur le
nécessaire investissement dans la
rénovation pour limiter les impacts du
réchauffement climatique en effet dans
un monde à plus deux degrés ou les
canicules seront de plus en plus
fréquentes les passoires thermiques
seront des logements surchauffés et mal
ventilés là où le froid s'engouffre en
s'infiltrera la chaleur d'été la
rénovation énergétique doit donc prendre
en compte le confort d'été afin de
proposer une solution qui soit durable
dans les décennies à venir et d'éviter
l'installation de climatiseurs
consommateur d'énergie et participant au
réchauffement de nos villes selon vous
comment mieux intégrer le confort d'été
dans les rénovations faut-il revoir les
référentiels de la re 20 20 et les
cahiers des charges faut-il réviser le
DPE pour y intégrer ce critère
comme de nombreuses personnes
auditionnées vous positionnez en faveur
d'une réorientation des aides vers des
rénovations globales performantes à
l'opposé de la politique actuelle
favorisant la rénovation au gestes sans
doute moins efficace mais choisis pour
permettre d'embarquer dans des
opérations de rénovation un plus grand
nombre de ménages afin de diminuer le
reste à charge des ménages qui est le
principal frein à la rénovation globale
vous préconisez dans votre étude un
financement dual cumulant aide d'État et
prêt plus accessible tout en augmentant
le prix du carbone concrètement combien
cela va-t-il coûter quel est le montant
d'aide nécessaire quel taux et quelle
durée pour les prêts préconisez-vous
quel prix de carbone serait adéquat le
besoin d'accompagnement des usagers
revient fréquemment aussi dans nos
auditions comme un impératif afin de
restaurer la confiance et d'orienter les
particuliers vers des rénovations
efficaces quelle est votre point de vue
à ce sujet Comment évaluez vous le
dispositif certes encore récent actuel
mon accompagnateur rénov comment
améliorer le service public de la
rénovation énergétique aujourd'hui
faut-il selon vous un guichet unique où
doit-on plutôt proposer une offre
unifiée finalement quel regard
portez-vous sur les solutions
alternatives de financement de la
rénovation par prêt hypothécaire et sur
la solution proposée par France
stratégie d'opérateurs ensemblier se
finançant sur les économies d'énergie
réalisée avant de vous laisser la parole
pour répondre à ses premières questions
et pour un propos introductif d'une
quinzaine de minutes il me revient de
vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte-rendu publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc monsieur dolquès et monsieur l'edez
a prêté serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité a levé la main droite
et à dire je le jure
je vous en remercie donc qu'on vous
laisse la parole et à l'issue de votre
présentation et des premières réponses
donc aux questions que je viens de vous
poser notre rapporteur mais aussi nos
collègues qui assistent bien sûr à la
commission d'enquête ne manqueront pas
de vous poser d'autres questions c'est à
vous
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs et sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs nous allons répondre à
plusieurs des questions que vous avez
posées dans votre introduction mais
permettez-moi de répondre de présenter
d'abord rapidement notre structure donc
nous sommes un signe tank fondé par la
Caisse des dépôts et consignations et
l'Agence française de développement donc
on a été fondé en 2015 nous sommes une
association à but non lucratif qui
comptons à peu près 40 collaborateurs et
notre mission c'est de d'apporter une
expertise sur les politiques publiques
en matière d'atténuation et d'adaptation
changement climatique grâce à des
travaux d'analyse des travaux de
recherche appliqués
en matière de rénovation énergétique
nous avons mené ces dernières années
plusieurs travaux avec plusieurs angles
différents et ces travaux ont été
soutenus notamment par l'ADEME et le
ministère de la transition écologique
nous au cours de cette présentation nous
avons trois principaux messages clés à
vous présenter
si nous voulons respecter les objectifs
de la Stratégie nationale bas carbone il
va falloir davantage d'investissement en
faveur de la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments
avec une réorientation des
investissements en faveur des
rénovations globales
le deuxième message clé c'est que les
rénovations énergétiques globales ne
sont actuellement pas viables sur le
plan économique il y a deux grands types
de propositions qui sont formulés dans
le débat public et nous allons vous les
présenter
et le troisième message clé que nous
voulons vous partager c'est qu'il ne
faut surtout pas oublier l'enjeu de
l'adaptation dans le cas de rénovation
énergétique globale et qui a des actions
que nous pouvons mener déjà à court
terme et l'idée c'est d'éviter d'avoir
des deux rénovations dans les 30
prochaines années à la fois pour
l'atténuation et l'adaptation l'idée
c'est d'intégrer ces deux enjeux à la
fois dans tout projet de rénovation je
laisse maintenant la parole à Guillaume
pour présenter les objectifs en matière
de stratégie nationale de carbone et
aussi d'adaptation
bonjour à tous merci de votre invitation
je souhaitais tout d'abord revenir dans
mon propos liminaire sur les objectifs
de la SNBC tel qu'elle a été axée en
2020 même si celle-ci est en cours de
révision la snvc telle qu'elle est
tactée vise un parc entièrement
décarboné à l'horizon 2050 avec une
baisse drastique des consommations
énergétiques du secteur à la même
échéance
tel que cette objective est traduit dans
la SNBC elle parle d'un parc à niveau
basse consommation au niveau BBC en
moyenne en 2050 pour atteindre cet
objectif cela passe d'abord par des
constructions neuves évidemment très
performante mais surtout puisque la
grande majorité du parc qui sera qui
sera disponible en 2050 et
tu as rénové et non pas à construire
donc d'autre part ça implique une un
effort important de rénovation
énergétique donc sur la qualité des
parcs existants ceci pour deux objectifs
d'abord réaliser des économies d'énergie
de manière assez substantielle sur le
park existant et également réorienter
les les énergies qui sont actuellement
utilisées pour le bâtiment vers des
énergies qui sont bas carbone
cet objectif de niveau BBC en moyenne à
2050 implique plusieurs choses d'abord
d'accroître le niveau de le rythme
pardon de rénovation qui sont effectués
tous les ans pour atteindre 500 à 700
000 rénovations par an mais également et
surtout accroître la qualité des
rénovations qui sont effectivement
effectuées sur sur le territoire
plusieurs études dont certaines de
l'ADEME
préconisent que pour atteindre
finalement ce niveau BBC en moyenne en
2050 il faut que les logements soient
rénovés en une fois
ou en plusieurs si les gestes de travaux
sont coordonnés pour atteindre à terme
un niveau ou en tout cas viser le niveau
BBC pour chaque pour chaque logement
pourtant c'est ce n'est pas du tout ce
qu'on observe aujourd'hui dans le cadre
des plans de rénovation que l'on voit et
aujourd'hui la grande majorité des
rénovations qui sont conduites sont des
rénovations qui visent un poste de
travaux parfois plusieurs mais dans tous
les cas pas suffisamment coordonnées
pour que ce logement ce bâtiment
atteigne le niveau nécessaire à la
teinte et des objectifs de la SNBC à
terme
voilà c'est pour ça que nous dans la
suite de la présentation on parlera de
rénovation globale qui sont pour nous
les rénovations qui permettent
d'atteindre les objectifs de la SNBC
donc c'est à dire viser un niveau un
niveau rénovateur BBC rénovation de
chaque logement à terme
si tu peux passer
donc ça c'était pour la partie
atténuation du changement climatique
s'agissant de l'adaptation
c'est un sujet qui commence à apparaître
aujourd'hui parce que on le voit le
climat commence déjà à poser problème
dans les bâtiments publics ça par
exemple été le cas lors du passage du
bac en 2022 ou on a vu des conditions
particulièrement dégradées pour pour les
étudiants mais également pour les
logements qui vous l'aviez dit madame la
Présidente mal isolée amène parfois des
problèmes sanitaires notamment
vis-à-vis des populations qui sont les
plus exposées
la meilleure manière de d'adapter les
bâtiments au changement climatique
finalement ce n'est pas de ce que Maxime
disait précédemment ce n'est pas de
réinvestir pour adapter ces bâtiments
mais c'est plutôt de profiter des
opérations de rénovation pour les
adapter parce qu'on ne pourra pas se
permettre d'investir deux fois c'est ni
tes techniques techniquement ni
économiquement souhaitable donc dès lors
ce qu'on préconise nous c'est
d'intégrer des exigences d'adaptation
dans l'ensemble des opérations qui sont
qui sont qui sont réalisées aujourd'hui
un petit mot et je te laisse la parole
Maxime nos travaux n'ont pas eu vocation
à chercher à savoir si la SNBC était la
manière la plus efficace économiquement
pour atteindre les objectifs de
neutralité de la France nous nous basons
sur les travaux de la SNBC et nous en
déduisons des besoins d'investissement
des freins mais aussi du coup des
retards d'investissement en lien avec
cette stratégie là et c'est cette partie
Maxime que tu vas pouvoir développer
exactement en fait
nous estimons les besoins
d'investissement associés à la stratégie
nationale Beck carbone et ce pour
l'instant dans trois secteurs le secteur
des bâtiments le secteur des transports
et les secteurs de la production
d'énergie et au sein du secteur des
bâtiments donc nous estimons un retard
d'investissement dans la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments donc il
faudrait plus 16 milliards d'euros
d'investissement en moyenne sur la
période 2021 2030 par rapport au niveau
historique observé en 2019 ce qui est un
besoin d'investissement supplémentaire
assez important
les investissements doivent croître sur
tous les segments du parc que ce soit
résidentiel privé sociale ou tertiaire
public et privé et notamment les
collectivités territoriales doivent
doubler leurs investissements dans la
rénovation de leur parc tertiaire
il y a une question de volume
d'investissement en tant que tel de la
quantité d'euros que l'on va
effectivement dépenser pour la
rénovation des bâtiments mais aussi la
question de la qualité et en fait
aujourd'hui les 18 milliards d'euros que
nous observons donc dans la rénovation
énergétique c'est beaucoup de
rénovations partielles donc des
rénovations monogestes et l'enjeu c'est
aussi d'avoir des rénovations qui sont
de plus en plus globales donc il y a un
sujet de réorientation des
investissements vers des rénovations
globales qui permettent donc d'atteindre
le niveau basse consommation ou presque
alors pourquoi on a beaucoup de
rénovations partielles et très peu de
rénovations globale actuellement déjà on
peut regarder du côté des aides pour la
rénovation énergétique ici vous voyez
une croissance des aides qu'il y a eu
lieu sur la dernière décennie et on
atteint à peu près un peu plus de 8
milliards d'euros d'aide que ce soit des
certificats d'économie d'énergie la TVA
t'aurait dit ou encore ma prime rénove
qui ont été attribués au ménage pour la
rénovation énergétique des logements
privés et à peu près 500 millions
d'euros déco prêt à taux zéro qui ont
été versés
or parmi tous ces instruments de
financement ils permettent notamment de
financer des rénovations à geste unique
notamment si vous prenez ma prime rénov
vous avez un peu plus de 600 000 ménages
qui ont bénéficié de cette aide en 2021
et si on regarde la part de rénovation à
geste unique elle est assez importante
de l'ordre de 83 % et il y a des
rénovations qui permettent de réduire de
manière significative les consommations
énergétiques de l'ordre de plus de 35%
dans le cas des dispositifs sérénités et
copropriétés mais qui sont pas forcément
alignés avec l'objectif de la stratégie
nationale de carbone à savoir
d'atteindre un niveau BBC ou presque
et donc c'est aussi le cas pour d'autres
dispositifs notamment les certificats
d'économie d'énergie ou une approche
geste par geste sans objectif
d'atteindre un niveau de rénovation
globale et aussi les coprées à taux zéro
ou en fait la plupart des ménages qui
aujourd'hui choisissent un écho prêt à
taux zéro en fait finance un travaux des
travaux pardon monogestes
donc il y a la question des aides à la
rénovation mais il y a aussi d'autres
freins qui expliquent un manque
d'investissement dans la rénovation
globale déjà il y a une méconnaissance
de la part des ménages sur la question
de la qualité thermique des logements en
tant que tel
32% des ménages en maison considèrent
qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de travaux alors
que quand on regarde justement le nombre
de logements qui sont classés A ou B sur
le DPE il y en a à peu près 5%. donc les
ménages n'estiment pas qu'il y a besoin
de réaliser des travaux alors que la la
nation en tant que tel enfin la
stratégie nationale bas carbone vise
justement à ce que
il y a beaucoup plus de enfin plus de
ménage qui considèrent qu'il faut
réaliser des travaux en pratique aussi
vous avez une réglementation qui existe
mais qui est peu connue ou bien peu
respecté et pas forcément contrôlé
notamment donc la règlementation
thermique sur l'existant notamment dans
le cas de travaux de ravalement de
façade ou de réflexion de toiture et
donc déjà il y a le sujet n'est pas
forcément embarqué quand il y a des de
tel travaux qui sont
lancés et les coûts considérés par les
ménages pour effectuer des travaux de
rénovation énergétiques sont estimés
comme important notamment vous devez
déménager quand vous devez faire des
travaux de rénovation globale vous devez
rencontrer plusieurs interlocuteurs que
ce soit votre banquier des entreprises
de travaux des maîtres d'oeuvre et donc
les coûts transactions sont assez lourds
et justifie peu les gains à leurs yeux
de rénovation énergétique enfin en tout
cas les gains que cela procure
ensuite vous avez un autre frein qui est
la question de l'offre sur les
territoires en matière de rénovation
aujourd'hui vous avez peu de
professionnels qui sont formés à
proprement parler sur la question de la
rénovation globale des bâtiments et donc
déjà il y a si vous n'avez pas d'offre
c'est difficile aussi de d'avoir de la
demande c'est l'éternité de la poule et
l'oeuf et en fait les entreprises qu'on
a sur le territoire travail très peu en
groupement enfin il y a très peu de
d'interactions entre différents corps de
travaux pour mener des travaux de
rénovation globale et donc il y a en
tout cas un manque à ce niveau là alors
il existe des initiatives dont on a
connaissance notamment l'initiative de
Rémi ou encore les sociétés de tiers
financement qui visent justement à faire
travailler des artisans ensemble mais en
tout cas pour l'instant ces initiatives
sont limitées
il y a des freins spécifiques aussi sur
certains segments du parc que vous avez
déjà enfin qu'on a suivi les auditions
on les avait déjà évoqué sur le segment
des copropriétés en tant que tel ou la
prise de décision est assez complexe
avec des libérations en assemblée
générale qui sont
difficiles et aussi le cas des logements
locatifs privés ou en fait il y a peu
d'incitation pour les propriétaires à
rénover les propriétaires bailleurs
parce que en fait une personne pas
directement les gains procurés par les
économies d'énergie et de l'autre côté
le locataire a peu d'intérêt à rénover
un logement pour lequel il n'est pas sûr
de rester plusieurs années
et enfin il y a un autre frein qui est
donc la question de l'offre des
financements en tant que tel et je
laisse
Guillaume présenter ça en plus en détail
dans le cas de nos travaux sur les aides
publiques
merci Maxime
[Musique]
dans le cadre de ce projet le
constat de départ était justement de se
dire que sur le territoire il y avait
très peu de rénovation globale qui était
entreprise
et probablement que l'offre de
financement qui était proposée était en
inadéquation avec les besoins des
ménages ça c'était le constat de base
pour aller un peu plus loin dans ce
constat on a essayé de mieux comprendre
la manière dont les différents systèmes
d'aide les différents contextes
économiques influe sur le finalement le
raisonnement économique d'aménage la
perception qu'il a de ce système
lorsqu'il souhaite se lancer dans un
travaux de rénovation
donc pour ça on a développé un petit
outil qui analyse pour chaque projet
donc un projet une maison un type de
rénovation un revenu d'aménage il
analyse la viabilité économique de ce
projet c'est à dire finalement
dans quelle mesure le ménage
est favorable donc du point de vue
économique à se lancer ou pas dans des
travaux de rénovation et ce concept de
viabilité économique finalement il a
articulé autour de trois notions c'est
celle que vous que vous voyez sur sur la
slide la première c'est que pour qu'un
ménage décide de se lancer dans un
projet de relation celui-ci doit être
abordable c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment
donné il faut pas que au moment de se
lancer dans les projets de travaux de
rénovation ils doivent
vider son livret en fait il faut il faut
pouvoir compter sur des subventions ou
des prêts pour éviter de de trop
demander à la trésorerie du ménage qui
parfois soit inexistante soit simplement
la rénovation n'est pas un bien de luxe
donc c'est pas c'est pas forcément
quelque chose sur lequel le ménage
souhaiterait ce
voilà dépenses dépenser son argent
le projet de relation doit également
être profitable c'est à dire que
finalement à un moment donné si le
ménage doit se lancer dans ce projet là
il doit pouvoir percevoir un bénéfice à
le faire et ce bénéfice là c'est avant
tout des économies d'énergie
qu'ils doivent justifier les coûts
engagés les montants de rénovation
globale sont généralement assez élevés
et si le ménage ne perçoit pas des
économies d'énergie à un temps de retour
suffisamment court il risque de se
décourager finalement de se lancer dans
ces opérations de rénovation
et la dernière notion c'est la notion de
solvabilité le moins l'idée derrière
c'est que on ne peut pas demander à
ménage notamment au ménage les plus
modestes 200 DT à des taux qui sont trop
élevés en les exposant dans ce cas là à
des risques de surendettement ou alors
que les mensualités des prêts finalement
soit plus élevées que les économies
d'énergie perçues dans les cas des
projets de rénovation et dans ce cas le
risque c'est de grever finalement les
dépenses courantes des ménages
donc cet outil là on l'a développé voilà
autour de ce concept de viabilité
économique et de ces trois notions donc
des projets de rénovation qui doivent
être abordables profitables et solvables
tu peux y aller du coup si on regarde
maintenant les conditions actuelles
on va vous présenter un petit exemple
très simple dans lequel on a passé du
coup une rénovation qui est
tout à fait classique en rénovation
globale et l'idée c'était de la passer
aux prismes des conditions actuelles en
ce cas là on va considérer un un cas de
figure où on a un ménage aux revenus
modestes qui souhaitent rénover sa
maison pour passer de l'étiquette e à
l'étiquette B des traduits de rénovation
s'élève à 55000 euros donc des coûts de
travaux moyens pour des rénovations
globales
dans les conditions actuelles le ménage
ne peut prétendre donc aménage aux
revenus modeste ne peut prétendre qu'à
environ 35% de subventions le reste
étant à sa charge si tu peux
donc finalement ce qui lui reste à
débourser c'est 36000 euros donc un
ménage
à ce niveau de revenu risque finalement
de se décourager avant même de
considérer des solutions d'emprunt ou de
financement pour se reste à charge avec
un niveau aussi élevé de subventions
pardon de reste à charge si tu peux
passer les deux d'un coup comme ça je
vais voilà je vais parler de la deuxième
en outre du coup quand il va regarder le
les montants qui sont à sa charge il va
regarder les mettre en parallèle de ces
économies d'énergie et finalement ce qui
se constate sur ce projet c'est que les
économies d'énergie ne sont rentabilisés
que après un temps très long qui est
supérieur à 10 ans donc là encore on a
un facteur qui risque de de décourager
le ménage de se lancer on a un reste à
charge qui est très élevé qui récupérera
que dans un terme qui est très long
et la dernière chose donc si ce ménage
un peu malgré tout passe un peu ces
barrières là et considère un emprunt
donc notamment à travers les coptz et
puis finalement on voit que le taux
d'endettement il est relativement élevé
autour de 5% donc pour un projet de
rénovation énergétique et là encore ça
risque d'éloigner le ménage du crédit
déjà parce que les banques pourraient
être frileuses à lui octroyer auprès et
quand bien même elle lui octroie on
aurait possiblement un risque de
surendettement donc là dessus on vous a
montré un exemple simple de ce que
veulent dire les conditions actuelles
aujourd'hui pour le revenu déménage
modestes mais finalement quand on passe
aujourd'hui dans les conditions
actuelles plusieurs catégories de
revenus de ménage et plusieurs projets
de rénovation en fait on voit que
finalement ces conditions-là se répètent
de manière assez régulière et donc en
tout cas d'un point de vue économique on
peut considérer qu'on a là un vrai frein
à lancer un véritable programme
ambitieux de rénovation globale quand on
parlait de plusieurs centaines de
milliers de rénovation tous les ans
alors dans le dans le débat public vous
avez deux grandes types de propositions
que nous nous distinguons il y a une
première série de propositions qui vise
à lister le coup de la rénovation grâce
à l'endettement et aux économies
d'énergie donc l'idée c'est de
développer une ingénierie financière
avec des prêts et qui permettent à la
fois donc d'assurer l'équilibre entre
trésorerie pour les ménages et de
maîtriser la dépense publique vous avez
comme exemple de propositions celle
formulées entre autres par l'association
négaWatt et le réseau clair sur les
obligations conditionnelles de
rénovation énergétique vous avez celle
de l'opérateur en sanglier pour France
stratégie ou encore le fond pour la
diminution de consommation d'énergie des
bâtiments donc de Maxime combe monsieur
Ibanez et Madame Berchère que vous avez
auditionné il me semble donc
d'accord très bien bah voilà
donc je voulais en venir donc là dans
l'idée où on a fait les ménages enfin le
ménage modeste comme on l'a vu pouvait
contracter en effet un écho prêt à taux
zéro et supposons sur 30 ans vous avez
bien un équilibre trésorerie qui est
assuré pour le ménage donc les économies
d'énergie en tant que tel permettent de
rembourser les mensualités de
remboursement ce qui est intéressant et
le taux d'endettement est relativement
limité mais par contre vous avez un
reste à charge donc avant même de
considérer emprunt qui reste assez élevé
et donc il peut décourager même le
ménage de décider de vouloir contracter
un prêt parce que en fait on parle de
quand même lors de 30-40 000 euros de
prêt donc c'est quand même une somme non
négligeable et les conditions de
rentabilité ne sont toujours pas
respectées vous avez un temps de retour
sur investissement qui est de facto
encore assez long et aussi vous avez
donc si vous regardez la facture avec
valeur actuelle nette elle n'est pas
positive
d'ici 15 ans
et donc il y a aussi nous ce que nous
voulons souligner par rapport à cette
série de propositions on voit deux enfin
deux principales interrogations enfin en
tout cas deux questions qu'on se pose
déjà c'est comment faire en sorte que
les établissements crédits distribution
distribués des prêts parce que en
pratique c'est prêt existent mais de
facto il est peu distribué par les par
les banques
or pourquoi ça peut distribuer déjà
parce que les établissements bancaires
considèrent que distribuer les cours
prêt à taux zéro c'est pas suffisamment
rentable mais en tout cas les marges
sont très faibles
étant donné les coins administratifs que
cela représente en termes de
justification des dossiers que ce soit
les travaux de rénovation énergétique
les catégories de ménage etc les banques
considèrent que ce travail est trop
lourd par rapport à l'aide que propose
l'État en matière de crédit d'impôt pour
pour financer ces pertes d'intérêt
donc il y a déjà ça et alors les auteurs
proposent souvent plusieurs solutions
notamment la question de la
réglementation on déclenche plein de
rénovations performantes parce que en
fait il va avoir un énorme niveau de
demande avec le 500 000 rénovations
globales par an grâce aux mutations
enfin des obligations sur les notations
immobilières et donc les banques auront
intérêt justement à se positionner sur
ce marché ou bien d'avoir un recours à
une banque publique si personne ne
souhaite prêter directement en ménage et
bien les ménages seront orientés donc
avec la banque vers la banque postale ou
une autre banque publique qui
accepterait donc de qui n'auront pas le
choix en fait qui aura l'obligation donc
de financer ce cette opération
aussi un autre point d’investissement
c'est la question
du risque en tant que tel
en fait déjà il y a des risques par
rapport au coût des travaux enfin les
coûts des travaux ne sont pas forcément
maîtrisés la question des économies
d'énergie se pose aussi donc les
éléments trésorerie peuvent varier et si
je prends le cas particulier des
opérateurs en sangliers ou c'était une
des questions que vous avez posées dans
votre introduction en fait le quand on
regarde le modèle économique même des
opérateurs à sangliers alors actif en
fait il y a des contrats de fournitures
d'énergie sur une durée assez longue la
question se pose c'est est-ce que les
ménages souhaiteraient enfin avoir des
têtes contrats de fournitures d'énergie
sur des temps longs de s'engager sur le
temps long ça c'est une vraie question
qu'on se pose et aussi quel acteur
voudront financer des opérateurs
ensemble liés parce qu'en fait on peut
considérer que l'actif est assez risqué
et donc ça suppose un dispositif de
garantie publique qui est derrière mais
la question qu'on se pose forcément
c'est de savoir ce que les garanties
publiques donneront effectivement à des
dépenses publiques
parce que les opérateurs vont s'envoyer
par exemple devront solliciter
finalement l'État pour compenser les
pertes
il y a aussi une donc une deuxième série
de propositions qui est beaucoup plus
centrée sur les subventions
là si on reprend notre exemple de ménage
tout à l'heure donc ensuite on supposant
qui est donc un taux de subvention de
l'ordre de 85% comme ça avait été
proposé par la mission de Michel les
travaux sont déjà plus abordables bien
sûr
largement les économies d'énergie
permettent de financer les mensualités
de prêt grâce aux grands niveaux de
subventions le taux d'endettement est
limité et encore plus limité
qu'auparavant et le projet désormais
rentable le temps de retour sur
investissement et vraiment assez court
et donc très attractif pour un pour un
ménage modeste par contre il y a
toujours la question du reste à charge
enfin 8000 euros
reste toujours à financer par un ménage
enfin doit être quand même couvert par
un prêt
là il y a d'autres interrogations qui se
posent à ce niveau là c'est la question
de la sodomie pour les budgets publics
parce que si on regarde justement ce qui
a estimé la mission d'échelle pour
rénover toutes les passoires thermiques
sur enfin un niveau BBC c'est l'ordre
ils ont estimé que c'était de l'ordre de
116 milliards d'euros d'aide si vous
rappelez ça sur 10 ans ça fait plus de
11 milliards d'euros d'aide sachant que
ça ce n'est pas forcément de la public
en tant que celle ça peut être des
certificats d'économie d'énergie mais il
y a pas eu de répartition qui a été
faite par la mission de
il peut y avoir une sorte de Paris
notamment il y a des modèles
macroéconomiques qui estiment bien une
augmentation des dépenses publiques
sur le temps court pour la rénovation
énergétique des logements mais il y a
aussi une sorte de retour en termes de
recettes fiscale avec des assiettes
fiscales qui augmenteraient notamment
plus de travaux donc une augmentation
des recettes issues de la TVA enfin
voilà donc
mais c'est une vraie question qui se
pose ce que les il y a pas des frictions
justement au niveau macroéconomique
sachant que si on fait beaucoup de
dépenses publiques est-ce que bah on va
voir vraiment un report effectif par
exemple de des artisans qui travaillent
sur des rénovations partielles vers des
rénovations globales il y a un vrai
sujet à ce niveau là et puis il y a la
question qui revient souvent des
pressions à flattinistes si vous faites
beaucoup plus de subventions il y a un
risque que les entreprises qui proposent
des travaux captent justement ces
subventions et propose en fait des
travaux plus chers et donc en fait il
reste on risque de rentrer dans un
cercle vicieux en matière de
de coût des travaux qui ont montré au
fur et à mesure que les subventions
augmentent
voilà donc on pourra revenir
éventuellement sur ces propositions si
vous voulez dans la session-réponse je
voulais juste Guillaume terminer sur la
question de l'adaptation
des bâtiments pardon
merci et donc là on va faire un petit
pas de côté par rapport à ce que tout ce
qu'on s'est dit sur les
l'investissement dans la rénovation pour
les objectifs de la SNBC là je vais
parler un petit peu adaptation
comme je vous le disais en introduction
les bâtiments aujourd'hui ils ne sont
pas conçus pour pour faire face au
changement climatique on le voit déjà
aujourd'hui on va le voir à l'avenir les
conditions que l'on connaît vont être
amenés à se répéter et à empirer on
parle des vagues de chaleur mais on peut
également parler du risque inondations
le risque retrait gonflement des argiles
qui commencent aussi à
soulever plusieurs questions
et les bâtiments tels qu'ils avaient été
conçus à l'époque ou tel qu'on continue
à le construire finalement ne tiennent
toujours pas compte de cette de cette de
cette nouvelle donne et aujourd'hui donc
en 2023 on continue à construire et à
rénover comme si le climat ne changeait
pas et
c'est important de prendre conscience de
ça parce qu'en fait chaque année le
marché du Bâtiment c'est 125 milliards
d'euros finalement c'est 125 milliards
d'euros ils sont investis dans des
projets sans même qu'on se pose la
question de de ces nouvelles conditions
alors même que l'on sait que les
bâtiments qui sont rénovés ou construits
aujourd'hui seront encore là en 2050 en
2060 donc ils comptent qui connaîtront
des conditions d'exploitation qui seront
probablement bien bien plus
dur que les conditions que les
conditions actuelles
en construction neuve c'est le cas aussi
avec la réglementation laro 2020 qui est
sorti cette année l'année dernière
pardon pour le pour lequel les
indicateurs par exemple de confort d'été
donc celui qui s'assure du confort en
période de canicule ne prend pas compte
des de l'évolution du climat et bien
basé sur un aléa passé et on peut se
demander si du coup cette année à là et
n'est pas obsolète compte tenu de
l'évolution du climat en rénovation
c'est un peu la même chose il n'y a
aujourd'hui pas de réglementation ni
aucune vraie incitation pour prendre en
compte le changement climatique donc
finalement comme on l'a vu la plupart
des travaux de rénovation qui sont
aujourd'hui entreprises ce sont des
travaux de rénovation d'un poste souvent
un remplacement de chaudière ou une
isolation et qui ne pose à aucun moment
la question de l'adaptation au
changement climatique à terme on a un
risque qui est très fort finalement de
ce que c'est ce que je disais un peu
précédemment de soit de voir réinvestir
massivement cette fois pour adapter les
le parc de bâtiments donc assez
inefficace techniquement économiquement
mais sinon et peut-être que c'est le
plus grand risque c'est de voir ce
matérialiser le recours massif à la à la
climative à la climatisation qu'on voit
et qu'on commence à avoir apparaître
notamment dans les logements avec la
climatisation de confort qui qui évolue
chaque année de manière quasi
exponentielle
concrètement comment est-ce qu'on s'y
prend et ben en rénovation c'est
intégrer des exigences de confort d'été
des exigences d'adaptation au chômage
climatique au moment de la réalisation
des projets
même si certains gestes isolés
permettent déjà d'améliorer le confort
par exemple simplement mettre des volets
ou des protections extérieures ou
remplacer un système de ventilation
améliore déjà le confort d'été
ça ne suffira probablement pas à
garantir un confort intérieur dans les
dans les années à venir pour les étés
qui vont connaître des canicules
probablement un peu plus fortes
rénover de manière globale ça permet
finalement de traiter de nombreux postes
de rénovation énergétique en même temps
et il y a un vrai intérêt à faire ces
travaux là en matière de confort d'été
au même moment parce que l'étanchéité
l'étanchéité à l'air excusez-moi d'un
bâtiment est un élément essentiel si on
garantisse si on garantit cette notion
là on sait déjà qu'on a traité une
partie du problème également au moment
de la rénovation globale surtout des
gros bâtiments ou des bâtiments publics
on peut vraiment se poser la question de
simulation thermique dynamique de
maîtrise d'oeuvre un peu poussée qui
permet vraiment d'intégrer ce type de
considération dans ce projet de
rénovation ce qui sera très probablement
pas le cas dans dans des opérations de
rénovation
ponctuel et ça on sait le faire on a
déjà des guides techniques qui sont qui
sont disponibles en matière de
d'adaptation des bâtiments il y a déjà
des des démarches exemplaires qui
mériteraient d'être mieux diffusé d'être
mieux connu par exemple l'exemple de la
démarche que je vous ai mis là c'est la
démarche bâtiment durable méditerranéen
qui œuvre à faire avancer la filière du
bâtiment sur l'ensemble des des
différentes notions de bâtiments durable
donc qui sont l'efficacité énergétique
l'adaptation des bâtiments le recours
aux matériau biosourcés etc etc mais
finalement ce sont des démarches qui
sont encore isolées qui mériteraient
finalement d'être mieux déployés sur le
territoire et surtout se sont encore des
démarches qui malheureusement se basent
encore sur des sur le climat actuel
notamment parce que les données de
climat futur ne sont pas encore
complètement disponibles en tout cas ne
sont pas opérationnels pour que les
maîtres de les mettre d'oeuvre les
professionnels du bâtiment s'en
saisissent directement dans leur
logiciel et puis déjà tenir compte de
l'adaptation changement climatique
lorsqu'il
il réalise des projets
et tu peux passer
quelques préconisations tu peux mettre
les trois quelques quelques
préconisations du coup pour aller dans
ce sens et ce sera la fin de la fin de
nos propos la première ça serait
peut-être déjà de
faire de la commande publique un levier
d'exemplarité pour adapter les bâtiments
notamment parce que la commande publique
exploite des bâtiments dont certaines
héberges des populations qui sont
parfois sensibles je pense par exemple
au bâtiment des collectivités qui
hébergent les collèges les lycées mais
aussi les écoles
on a là un vrai levier de de d'action
pour mieux prendre en compte
l'adaptation et notamment et c'est là où
c'est parfait parce qu'en fait
finalement on rejoint les objectifs de
d'atténuation avec les 7 objectifs de
rénovation des des bâtiments publics un
niveau BBC donc là on a un finalement
une très bonne opportunité pour
embarquer pour embarquer l'adaptation
on en a déjà beaucoup parlé donc je vais
pas forcément revenir dessus mais voilà
progressivement réorienter les aides à
la rénovation vers les projets les plus
performants qui permettront de mieux
tenir compte de l'adaptation ça
nécessitera aussi forcément des
accompagnateurs qui soient formés à ces
enjeux là parce que c'est quand même un
enjeu qui est assez émergent on pense
tout de suite par exemple aux
accompagnateurs françaises mais ça peut
également être le cas des artisans qui
sont finalement au plus près des
décisions notamment pour les ménages et
qui sans formation spécifique risque de
passer un peu à côté de ces objectifs
et ça ça fait le lien du coup avec notre
troisième levier qui est finalement
qu'aujourd'hui on a on a un vrai besoin
de monter en compétences de l'ensemble
de la filière et pour ça on a plusieurs
pistes notamment la recherche
on a vu ces dernières années le
programme prébate qui avait notamment
été porté par l'ADEM sur l'efficacité
énergétique des bâtiments il y a
peut-être également une opportunité pour
porter un programme de recherche pas
forcément spécifiquement pour
l'adaptation mais en tout cas qui
intégrerait ses nouveaux enjeux parce
que malgré le fait que les sociaux
techniques existent aujourd'hui on
manque encore de retour d'expérience et
ce problème de recherche pourrait
permettre justement de de faire sortir
de terre finalement des bâtiments
démonstrateurs qui prennent en compte
ces nouveaux ces nouveaux leviers mais
également de la sensibilisation et
notamment auprès de l'ensemble de la
maîtrise d'ouvrage que soit la maîtrise
d'ouvrage publique mais aussi des
particuliers finalement pour que
l'adaptation au changement climatique
devienne également une demande de la
part de ces maîtres d'ouvrage parce
qu'aujourd'hui que tant qu'on a pas
cette demande là finalement les les
prochaines ne sont pas incitées à les
intégrer dans leur cahier des charges
parce que les surcoûts qui sont qui sont
parfois nécessaires pour adapter les
bâtiments ils ne sont pas justifiés dès
lors que la demande n'est pas faite
voilà on a un vrai enjeu aussi sur ce
sujet là faire à faire monter la filière
et je m'arrêterai là pour l'adaptation
je suis pas sûr qu'on a répondu à toutes
vos questions on peut alors certainement
pas mais puisque je pense qu'il va y
avoir des regroupements et des questions
que va poser le rapporteur je pense que
vous arriverez à nous apporter des
réponses voilà donc je laisse la parole
au rapporteur
merci Madame les présidentes merci pour
votre votre exposé qui est intéressant
parce que en plus il poursuit la
discussion que nous avons eu juste avant
notamment sur la sur la prise en compte
de l'évolution climatique enfin plutôt
la non prise en compte révolution
climatique actuellement sur les sur les
politiques qui sont mises en place moi
j'avais d'abord une première question
c'est vrai que on voit bien du coup le
levier en tout cas qu'on qu'on cherche à
avoir pour à la fois aller vite et aller
vers de la rénovation globale et c'est
vrai que dans les différentes auditions
qu'on a pu avoir on se pose souvent la
question entre deux aspects d'ailleurs
qui pourrait être les deux à la fois sur
la citation et donc prier rénov est de
subventions et puis l'autre qui peut
être une obligation de rénovation
quel que soit d'ailleurs son sens mais
en tout cas c'est des c'est des
réflexions qu'on a pu avoir et à travers
différentes auditions et notamment sur
par exemple l'obligation de rénovation
des passoires lors de la vente c'était
par exemple ce que nous explique et je
crois que c'était François de Rugy quand
on l'a
quand on l'a auditionné que ça avait été
un débat en tout cas qui avait pu avoir
dans le choix qui a pas été retenu mais
cette idée qu'on pouvait obliger à la
rénovation lors de lors d'une vente
comme ça se fait notamment sur sur les
questions d'assainissement de mise en
conformité et puis l'autre exemple et ce
que vous avez pu montrer avec la
proposition
la proposition de loi citoyenne
Ibanez Combes notamment sur le fait de
dire voilà on a une obligation de de
rénovation de rénovation thermique
pour le coup sans reste à charge puisque
c'est financé par
un prêt avec une hypothèque sur la sur
la valeur et justement en fait ça
rejoint la proposition d'avant et
justement en gros on se rembourse en
tout cas sur sur la vente
donc voilà il y a des il y a des
propositions comme ça
et c'est vrai voilà votre avis entre les
solution S qui sont plus sur sur de
l'aide direct et celles qui sont plutôt
sur de sur de l'obligation
ensuite moi j'avais une question
peut-être sur le
vous avez dit qu'effectivement il
fallait plus 16 milliards d'euros global
si on voulait vraiment atteindre les
objectifs vous en avez un petit peu
parlé et notamment sur le point 3 mais
sur on voit bien qu'il y a bien décidé
d'avoir de l'argent et d'injecter de
l'argent mais derrière il y a toute la
question de la filière et de la capacité
à faire en fait et donc voir comment
justement à la fois sur le développement
de la filière le lien et la formation
des entreprises
la disponibilité des matériaux parce
qu'on a vu que ça aussi ça pouvait être
ça pouvait être un problème et qui
suffisait pas d'avoir les financements
donc en fallait-il avoir les matériaux
nécessaires et notamment aussi sur
l'aspect de la mise en place d'une
filière pour le coup plus locale et
notamment sur biosourcée puisqu'on va
avoir aussi cette demande déjà cette
demande avec laro 2020 mais on voit bien
aussi que là il y a l'intérêt de
développer justement du matériau de
sourcier qui en plus va dans plutôt dans
le bon sens notamment sur le confort
thermique d'été donc on a aussi quelque
chose d'intéressant qui va aussi sur la
captation carbone en tout cas le
stockage du carbone
donc pareil voir si vous aviez un peu
réfléchi à ça et ce lien en fait qu'on
peut avoir entre l'argent qu'on peut
mettre et puis la possibilité en face et
la montée en gamme de la filière qui est
pas forcément le le plus évident et puis
peut-être pour terminer c'est la place à
mes collègues sur la ce que vous avez
dit au début et c'est vrai que je trouve
qu'il y a une question qui revient de
plus en plus et qui moi je trouve et
peut être une dérive on va dire
inquiétante
c'est que souvent on a l'objectif 2050
et d'être en neutralité carbone et c'est
vrai que si on se fixe que sur cet
objectif il y a une solution très simple
c'est qu'on remplace
l'ensemble de nos moyens de chauffage
par du chauffage électrique que ce soit
d'ailleurs pompe à chaleur ou autre peu
importe en se disant que on a une
production électrique soit nucléaire etc
et donc des carbonées
et du coup on a plus besoin d'isoler
puisque le tour est joué quoi et je
trouve que c'est enfin c'est une dérive
en tout cas qui peut être parce qu'on
nous dit et on nous dit aussi enfin
j'entends la même chose qui se développe
sur la question de la climatisation et
du confort thermique d'été en disant on
va avoir des vagues de chaleur très
fortes en fait on n'aura jamais le temps
d'agir sur les bâtiments en matière
d'isolation donc bah faut accepter la
solution c'est la climatisation et je
trouve voilà et c'est vrai que si on
regarde que sur l'aspect carbone ça
marche c'est enfin en tout cas ça
pourrait marcher
et donc voilà comment comment on peut
allier les deux et en tout cas comment
faire peut-être attention à cette à
cette dérive parce que bon bah derrière
la réalisation des bâtiments c'est aussi
du confort c'est de la santé c'est enfin
voilà il y a d'autres évidemment
d'autres aspects
voilà pour la pour l'instant et puis
ce que vous souhaitez aussi qu'on
réponde aux questions que vous avez
posées en introduction génial ok alors
ok
d'abord alors il y avait une question
relative au guichet unique vous avez eu
des avis comme quoi certains additionnés
étaient en faveur d'un guichet unique et
d'autres étaient plutôt opposés
de notre côté nous n'avons pas d'avis
particulier à ce sujet on comprend les
arguments pour et contre à savoir
l'argument pour c'est plus simple en
terme de de pilotage de la politique
publique d'avoir un seul guichet en tant
que tel mais aussi on comprend les
arguments comptes notamment avec des
guichets qui sont adaptés à différents
types de ménages je pense notamment les
minages en situation de précarité qui
vont consulter des acteurs comme Solia
ou des ménages qui sont en situation de
copropriété ou l'interlocuteur
privilégié le syndic mais en fait ils
peuvent très bien justement enfin ces
acteurs réorientés vers justement des un
homme typiquement un accompagnateur
rénov qui après propose justement une
offre de financement donc
voilà je pense que c'est pas forcément
comment dire un point c'est plus le
déploiement de mon accompagnateur Renov
qui est vraiment important à ce sujet là
et après savoir comment rediriger les
ménages vers les accompagnateur rénov en
cas de besoin de rénovation
vous avez posé également par une
question alors il y avait en
introduction sur la question de la fosse
qualité carbone et quel niveau de prix
du carbone serait judicieux dans le cas
de nos travaux sur panel reynov
je pense que Guillaume va plutôt
répondre en effet
alors
concernant la fiscalité carbone
[Musique]
la manière dont on a travaillé dans le
cadre de de du projet dont je vous
parlais précédemment sur le la capacité
des ménages à se lancer dans les projets
de rénovation en fait on a regardé
de quelle manière l'instauration d'une
fiscalité carbone ambitieuse pouvait
permettre de déclencher ou non des des
rénovations globales
et pour ça on a regardé notamment
on a fait une simulation qui est
particulièrement importante on a coupé
l'entièreté du système d'aide on a
proposé un prêt à un taux très faible
sur du temps très long qui couvrirait
les économies d'énergie pour permettre
en fait au ménage de pouvoir se lancer
sans grever ses dépenses dans les
projets de rénovation et ensuite on a
posé une composante carbone qui monte
jusqu'à 250 euros la tonne assez
rapidement et on a vérifié si dans ces
conditions-là le projet était rentable
pour le ménage en fait l'idée derrière
était de se dire la fiscalité de carbone
peut-elle se substituer au système
d'aide tel qu'il est fait aujourd'hui
les conclusions de cette simulation
c'est que non si on prend la composante
carbone toute seule finalement les
projets de relation gardent des Valeurs
Actuelles nettes des rentabilités qui
restent qui restent très faibles si
elles ne sont pas subventionnées parce
que finalement les économies d'énergie
ne sont pas suffisantes pour même en
regardant des du coup des montants de
factures qui augmentent tous les ans
elles ne sont pas elles ne sont pas
assez rentables pour que les ménages se
lancent dans dans ce projet ensuite on a
regardé une deuxième chose on s'est
demandé quel devrait être le niveau de
taxe carbone donc en fait finalement le
quelle est la quel est le montant de la
facture pour qu'un ménage se lance dans
un projet de rénovation énergétique si
celui-ci n'est pas subventionné donc en
fait il faut que la facture augmente de
manière si élevée que le ménage se dise
tiens finalement en quelques années je
rentabilise tout de suite mon
investissement et pour ça en fait on
atteint des niveaux de composantes de
carbone qui sont extrêmement élevés de
l'ordre de près de 1000 euros la tonne
donc finalement c'est un niveau qui est
assez insoutenable par ailleurs
finalement ces deux éléments
la conclusion contient de ces deux
éléments c'est de se dire que la
composante carbone ou la fiscalité
carbone à elle seule ne permettra pas de
rendre rentable des projets de relation
globale si on ne se sert que de ce
mécanisme par contre lorsque celui-ci
est couplé avec des subventions comme
c'est comme les subventions actuelles ou
avec des prêts finalement dans un mix de
politique publique on lui trouve un
terrain d'intérêt parce qu'en fait il
accroît la rentabilité des projets de
rénovation c'est à dire qu'un ménage qui
va se lancer dans son projet s'il sait
par avance et c'est la visibilité que
peut donner une fiscalité carbone si
c'est par avance que sa facture va
augmenter il aura de plus en plus
intérêt à mesure que la que la
composante carbone croit à se lancer
dans des dans des projets de la nation
énergétique
je voulais juste aussi préciser que dans
notre outil c'est important d'en avoir
conscience
c'est déjà qu'on suppose que
l'information est parfaite pour le
ménage que le ménage anticipe bien dans
le temps que la composante carbone va
augmenter et de comprendre l'impact sur
la facture énergétique en tant que tel
ce qui est dans le cas pratiquement le
casque et aussi l'hypothèse qu'il y a
c'est qu'il y a un accès limité au
crédit que en fait la courroie de
distribution toutes les échos prêtes au
zéro marche très bien et c'est ce qu'on
constate pas pour l'instant aussi je
voulais revenir sur une question que
vous aviez posé c'était sur le sujet des
du combien de dépenses publiques
supplémentaires et ça va être en écho
par rapport à ce que Guillaume disait ça
dépend beaucoup en fait du mix on n'a
pas de on n'a pas formulé vraiment de
recommandations de subventions publiques
en tant que tel ou de mise de
financement à mettre en oeuvre en fait
on a un panel à travers notre
publication on a un panel de de si
logements mais qui n'a pas vocation à
être représentative du tout de tout le
parc de logement enfin déjà il y a la
question des copropriétés qui est
particuliers il y a des questions aussi
des des propriétaires bailleurs et enfin
des logements locatifs privés donc on
n'a pas de d'ordre de grandeur mais par
contre on retient en tout cas la
proposition enfin
voilà la proposition de la mission
d'échelle qui était de l'ordre pour
rénover toutes les passoires thermiques
en disant c'est 11,6 milliards d'aide
donc ça peut te donner déjà un premier
ordre de grandeur après il y a des
propositions qui visent justement
atténuer la dépense publique comme je
vous l'ai présenté ou encore même à
l'augmenter
ensuite en termes de questions pardon
sur l'accompagnement que l'on préconise
notamment avec le dispositif mon
accompagnateur Renov en tout cas on
trouve les propositions
énoncées par la Mission échelle en la
matière très intéressante notamment nous
que la plateforme digitale mais qui est
quand même complexe intégrer à la fois
la question des financements des
propositions de financement des banques
les offres de travaux enfin c'est quand
même quelque chose de complexe mais
c'est surtout l'accompagnement humain
qui est aussi un vrai sujet parce qu'en
fait l'accompagnateur est neuve c'est
quelqu'un qui aurait des très bonnes
compétences en matière technique en
matière financière mais aussi qui a on
va dire un savoir aide pour accompagner
les ménages qui est dans une démarche
commerciale et donc des profils comme
celui-ci en fait il y en a pas il y en a
pas partout malheureusement donc c'est
un vrai sujet aussi on parle beaucoup de
besoins de former la filière du bâtiment
en la matière mais aussi une
donc ça c'est vraiment un enjeu mais je
pense que justement à travers le
dispositif on accompagnateur rénov il va
ça permet de muscler un peu cette
filière justement en rendant des travaux
qui font autant en rendant obligatoire
le dispositif pour certains types de
travaux donc c'est déjà une piste
intéressante et la question c'est de
savoir comment ensuite on va orienter
cette dispositif vers l'accompagnement
des rénovations globales et ça pour
l'instant il n'y a je crois pas que les
pouvoirs publics ont donné des lunettes
à ce sujet
je peux par la suite
dans vos propos liminaires vous aviez
évoqué la question du DPE et notamment
de son adaptation dans un monde qui
évolue
on n'a pas aujourd'hui de travaux à
proprement parler sur le sujet mais
d'après un peu les retours qu'on a pu
avoir il nous semble que le DPE c'est
déjà un outil qui est qui est assez
complexe pour les pour les particuliers
et qui demande un certain temps
d'appropriation car il y a beaucoup
d'informations
dedans d'ailleurs il y a déjà des
premières estimations de confort d'été
donc finalement des premières prises en
compte de ce sujet là mais qui pourrait
effectivement être améliorée en fait
finalement c'est c'est quasiment
l'ensemble des diagnostics qui sont
livrés au moment de la mutation qui
pourrait évoluer quand on regarde
aujourd'hui au monde du mutation on
reçoit de la part de du diagnostiqueur
l'ensemble de la carte des risques de
d'un logement ou d'un bâtiment
finalement l'ensemble de ces risques là
sont les risques tels qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui dictés dans les différents
documents de d'urbanisme de la ville
alors que un bâtiment qui aujourd'hui en
risque faible inondation en retrait
gonflement des argiles pourraient très
bien se retrouver en risque fort d'ici
quelques années voire quelques décennies
et avec des implications économiques qui
peuvent être radicalement différentes
aujourd'hui une maison fissurée par du
retrait gonflement des argiles c'est une
maison qui sur le marché a perdu toute
sa valeur donc c'est possible voilà on a
il y a possibilité
à regarder à regarder de ce côté là
sur le site des diagnostics de
performance on a vu d'autres outils qui
qui commencent à développer qui qui nous
semble intéressant de souligner je
voulais notamment parler du Diagnostic
de Performance résilience qui est
qui a été porté par le groupe CDC
habitat pour
passer au crible finalement de des aléas
et des risques physiques de son de son
de son parc
du coup l'ensemble de son parc de son
parc immobilier ce type d'outil permet
du coup à l'échelle d'un parc à
l'échelle d'un bailleur social de
vraiment créer une véritable stratégie
d'adaptation sur du long terme qui
permet de coupler l'ensemble de ces
opérations qui sont prévues par ailleurs
donc des opérations de rénovation
énergétique des opérations de
maintenance pour accroître l'adaptation
au moment de ces de ces opérations là et
ce type d'outil à l'échelle d'un parc
permet également du coup d'ordonnancer
finalement les travaux en fonction des
poches de vulnérabilité les plus les
plus importantes pour définir du coup le
cadre de ce que serait un diagnostic de
performance idéale en matière de de
résilience du coup on pourrait se
rapprocher de ces de ce type de démarche
il y a aussi du coup il y en a d'autres
j'avais mentionné par exemple le
l'association envirobal DDM qui a du
coup développé toute une démarche tout
un
label avec des critères qui fait déjà
référence dans la zone géographique de
son implantation
et ce type de mélange pourrait être
mieux diffusé mieux mieux mieux mieux
mieux structuré et partager par
l'ensemble des des acteurs de la filière
je peux je peux peut-être je vais
enchaîner si vous voulez du coup
toujours sur le côté adaptation on a
parlé vous aviez parlé rapidement de la
R20
je vais en parler rapidement parce que
là on est plutôt sur du neuf mais c'est
pareil on a l'impression que c'est un
sujet important
du coup qui est sorti l'année dernière
[Musique]
il y a déjà aujourd'hui des acteurs
techniques qui ont produit des choses
sur la question de l'intégration des
risques dans les opérations je pense par
exemple le prix qui a qui a publié
récemment un rapport sur comment mieux
intégrer le récit inondation au moment
des opérations de construction et de
rénovation ou l'appel à projet mieux
comment mieux bâtir pardon en terrain
inondable qui est également à produit
des des projets qui sont intéressants à
l'un du coup de ces de ces nouveaux
risques climatiques
alors ensuite sur question de monsieur
le rapporteur sur les sujets incitation
et obligations enfin
quelle solution privilégiée
c'est on n'a pas de d'avis sur le sujet
il y aura sûrement besoin un peu des
deux enfin de à la fois enfin c'est pas
forcément exclusif l'un et l'autre en
terme de politique d'avoir des
incitations et des obligations la
question c'est quels incitations et
quelles obligations il faudrait mettre
en oeuvre qui permettent à la fois
justement comme les bien dit de
développer la filière aussi de la
question d'avoir la disponibilité des
matériaux donc c'est vraiment un sujet
sur lequel on va se pencher dans nos
travaux à venir au sein de la Force
justement savoir quel scénario de
financement on peut établir pour la
rénovation énergétique des logements
plus tard et quelles interactions avec
le sujet de la réglementation en tout
cas nous défendons l'idée à efforcier
d'avoir une programmation pure annuelle
des financements en faveur de la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
mais pas que enfin aussi d'autres sujets
de la transition énergétique justement
pour donner de la visibilité aux acteurs
que ce soit les maîtres d'ouvrage ou
bien même la filière du bâtiment ou bien
même des structures d'accompagnement
pour pouvoir en fait se positionner sur
des marchés et se dire que c'est marcher
c'est son avenir en fait aujourd'hui
vous avez une stratégie nationale back
carbone qui existe mais en fait elle est
elle est pas jugée comme un signal
encore
enfin un peu serviette crédible en tout
cas par les acteurs enfin
de facto il y a peu de professionnels en
fait qui se forment à la rénovation
globale donc en fait pour une stratégie
à une stratégie il faut des moyens
adopter enfin adapté pardon à cette
stratégie et ça passe notamment à donner
de la visibilité sur les subventions les
offres de prêt mais aussi tout ce qui
est en matière de
dispositifs d'accompagnement et aussi
éventuellement des réglementations
en tout cas ça c'est c'est un message
important et donc on rejoint notamment
d'autres personnes auditionnées qui
justement sont en faveur de cette
programmation pure annuelle des
financements pour donner de la
visibilité sur le temps long
sur la question de notamment de des
matériaux biosourcés nous engageons
actuellement des travaux pour justement
savoir
comment faire en sorte
qu'il y a des comment dire plus de
matériaux bouillir à sorcés qui soient
intégrés dans le la question de la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments ce
sont des travaux qui seront disponibles
cet été on pourra vous les communiquer
si vous le souhaitez
en tout cas
c'est clairement que un sujet on va dire
gagnant-gagnant en effet on a besoin de
déboucher pour la filière filière bois
c'est de la séquestration du carbone
comme vous l'avez dit et en tout cas
c'est intéressant de se pencher aussi
sur ce qu'on entreprit notamment
d'autres pays nos voisins européens
notamment certains ont décidé de
subventionner davantage les matériaux
biosourcés que d'autres matériaux et
donc ça ça peut être aussi une piste
intéressante sachant qu'il faut
développer cette filière four et bois
donner des débouchés en tout cas à la
filière pour qu'elle soit en effet plus
local et ça permet de séquestrer du
carbone
ensuite vous avez
vous aviez évoqué la question de la
dérive en effet justement de se
concentrer essentiellement sur le fait
de décarboner les systèmes de chauffage
et de d'avoir recours
massivement à la climatisation et
confort d'été en fait le sujet pour nous
est traité aucun dans le cadre de la
stratégie française énergie climat qui
est en cours de préparation ça doit être
un sujet de débat justement
entre pouvoir politique donc en effet je
pense que ça c'est un j'ose espérer que
c'est un vrai un vrai point de vigilance
qu'on les les personnes qui préparent
cette stratégie
on a juste ce point-là après nous nous
n'avons pas de de stratégie privilégiée
au sein de notre institution de mon
cherche juste à implémenter une
stratégie qui est qui a acté et qui
décidait par plusieurs acteurs peut-être
un point sur rapide sur la climatisation
alors vous avez évoqué le fait de
d'abandonner de laisser les bâtiments
accéder à la climatisation alors c'est
vrai qu'on pourra on pourra pas s'en
passer partout c'est l'impression en
tout cas qu'on a et c'est les remontées
de terrain qu'on qu'on commence à
entendre il y a des zones sur lequel
effectivement on pourra pas s'en passer
il y aura certains usages qui devront
être privilégiés je pense notamment les
bâtiments qui hébergent des populations
qui sont les plus vulnérables pourtant
est-ce que cela veut dire déployer
massivement la climatisation partout
c'est a priori pas souhaitable
du coup cela impose plusieurs plusieurs
plusieurs aspects d'abord c'est
justement de
d'investir dans la rénovation des
bâtiments pour pour éviter ça mais en
fait on peut même aller un peu plus loin
en fait on peut dès aujourd'hui et ça ça
revient à tenir compte de l'évolution du
climat c'est prévoir finalement dans les
opérations
des solutions pour intégrer du froid
peut-être plus tard que
à ce moment là parce que aujourd'hui les
conditions ne sont pas forcément réunies
pour imposer cette climatisation et ça
ça peut donc notamment passer par des
des choix techniques qui permettent
justement d'attendre soit des évolutions
techniques aux réglementaires pour pour
mieux prendre en compte pour mieux
prendre en compte cet aspect là voilà
sur la climatisation
c'est vrai qu'on pourra pas s'en passer
partout mais il y a d'importants
garde-fou je pense à mettre en place
pour justement éviter
les dérives qui sont liées et les
consommations énergétiques et de et des
missions de gaz à effet de serre qui
seront liés
merci Franck Montauger merci merci
madame la Présidente merci à tous les
deux je salue les travaux de manière
générale de votre de votre institut qui
sont toujours très très intéressants je
voudrais troc un peu trois quatre petits
sujets rapidement
dans le cas pratique que vous avez
présenté de la famille modeste là qui
procède à des à des travaux de
rénovation
est-ce que vous intégrez
non seulement les contraintes en matière
de rénovation énergétique de leur
habitat mais également les les
contraintes
supplémentaires
qui sont liés
au climat
et qui touche à des postes
contraints comme le transport par
exemple
voir l'alimentation etc parce que cet
aspect là des choses je pense qu'on peut
pas regarder la question de la
rénovation et du poste rénovation
indépendamment de ces autres postes dont
je pense que les coûts le temps passant
vont augmenter voilà et sa complexifie
évidemment la question de l'engagement
d'investissement notamment en matière de
rénovation énergétique mais on peut pas
l'évacuer on peut pas le on peut pas les
laisser de côté donc est-ce que ça c'est
pris en compte dans votre dans votre
dans le cas pratique que vous avez
présenté parce que ça me semble que ça
ça peut avoir de l'importance ma
deuxième question est-ce que selon vous
on peut espérer des économies d'échelle
sur les coûts de la mise en oeuvre des
techniques nécessaires
au respect de la réglementation en
matière de rénovation énergétique parce
que ça peut aussi c'est un point qui
peut qui peut peser pour le sur le sur
le sujet sur la question des des prêts
vous avez vous avez évoqué le prix du
carbone
il y a des spécialistes je peux j'en ai
un en tête que vous connaissez
certainement mieux que moi qui s'appelle
Christian Gaullier qui travaille sur la
question du prix du carbone
effectivement mais aussi des taux
d'actualisation que l'on utilise dans
les modèles décisionnels alors modèle
décisionnels qui peuvent toucher les
particuliers mais qui peuvent aussi
toucher évidemment le secteur bancaire
en tout cas tous les organismes de de
près potentiels et cet aspect là des
choses il a il peut avoir une importance
sur les choix et sur les décisions qui
sont prises sur la facilitation
éventuellement de l'engagement
d'investissement
et ma dernière question est-ce que alors
je sais pas si vous pourrez y répondre
vous l'avez effleurer est-ce que avait
la connaissance que vous avez du sujet
vous estimez que l'ambition qui est
posée avec des objectifs très clairs
notamment à échange de 2050 est-ce que
vous pensez que cette ambition est
réalisable elle est faisable qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de sa faisabilité
vous avez à de multiples reprises
parlées de la stratégie nationale bas
carbone qui si je l'ai bien compris vous
l'avez évoqué il y a à l'instant doit
être révisé dans le cadre de la loi etc
d'un nouvel stratégie vous grézonnez là
à stratégie nationale bas carbone
actuel
on est bien clair donc ma question en
rapport avec la question de la
faisabilité de tout ça c'est est-ce que
quels sont est-ce que la est-ce que pour
vous la stratégie nationale bacarbone va
devoir être ou devait être
reconsidérer aussi à l'aune des moyens
publics et privés qu'on peut consacrer à
ce sujet de la rénovation énergétique
voilà sachant qu'il y a urgence ça on en
est tous d'accord mais que voilà
il suffit pas de dire c'est urgent il
faut aller le plus vite possible pour y
arriver quoi compte-tu de la complexité
du du sujet voilà et donc en lien avec
ça est-ce que vous avez des
recommandations
adressés aux politiques sur le plan
législatif et éventuellement à
l'exécutif sur le plan réglementaire
est-ce que sur certains sujets de normes
de normalisation on n'est pas allé trop
loin est-ce que voilà un optimum étant à
trouver entre l'exigence technique et et
là et là et la faisabilité j'ai envie de
dire
économique si ce n'est financière du
sujet voilà merci merci
je commence
merci pour ces questions je vais je vais
commencer je laisserai Maxime
compléter alors sur le sur le pour
revenir un peu sur l'outil et la manière
dont on a dans ton modélise les
différents ménages qui se lancent ou pas
dans des travaux de rénovation
énergétique on ne prend pas on ne prend
pas en compte les contraintes techniques
du bâtiment en tant que tel
on regarde simplement
l'aspect économique donc en fait on
regarde si on reprend le cadre des
quatre freins que Maxime et qui est
précédemment précédemment on regarde
uniquement le frein économique donc
celui pour lequel le ménage se lancerait
ou pas dans un projet de rénovation d'un
point de vue purement économique
donc en fait on résout on résout une
partie de l'équation seulement
le reste à vivre finalement qui est la
question de fond quand on se place du
point de vue du foyer alors ça j'y viens
vous l'intérêt alors s'agit donc les
contraintes techniques on ne les regarde
pas si ce n'est que on se base sur des
relations globales qui ont effectivement
eu lieu sur le territoire donc c'est à
dire qu'en fait elles ont c'est des
rénovations qui sont qui ont été
effectuées donc il atteignent
effectivement l'étiquette B donc pour
celles qu'on vous a présenté au montant
qu'on vous a présenté voilà c'est la
seule chose qu'on regarde d'un produit
technique ensuite sur les contraintes de
trésorerie la manière dont on regarde
justement ce reste à vivre en fait c'est
ça fait partie des indicateurs qu'on a
retenus pour définir la viabilité
économique telle qu'on veut la présenter
à travers les trois notions abordables
solvable et profitable l'idée c'est que
en fait on tente vers un reste à charge
nul pour les ménages justement pour ne
pas grever ce reste à vivre et on
regarde du coup également l'équilibre en
trésorerie l'idée c'est que pour nous un
projet doit globalement rien coûter ou
très peu à la trésorerie du ménage au
moment où il doit débourser pour ses
travaux donc on doit soit il doit soit
les avoir sous forme de subvention soit
il doit pouvoir les emprunter donc ça
c'est à dire un reste à charge nul et
l'équilibre en trésorerie
oui mais en fait bien sûr bien sûr mais
du coup ça en deux temps au moment des
travaux il doit rien avoir à débourser
c'est le pré dans si si un reste à
charge c'est le prix qu'il le fait et le
prix lui doit être au moins couvert par
les économies d'énergie c'est à dire
qu'en fait finalement le ménage doit
forcément avoir une opération positive à
la fin même si elle devient le retour
survissement peut-être très long et ça
c'est notamment ce qu'on a montré que
c'était dans le cas actuel ça peut
encore décourager le ménage dans tous
les cas on a quand même des conditions
pour les ménages modestes qui devraient
permettre de déclencher certaines
rénovations
sur l'économie d'échelle est-ce que tu
veux dire
un mot sur les économies des échelles
il y a la mise en oeuvre des techniques
de rénovation énergétique il y a déjà eu
une étude qui a été faite conduite par
l'ADEME en la matière ou en fait c'est
justement autour de d'un dispositif qui
s'appelle parfum mind où ils ont réuni
justement des groupements d'artisans et
en faisant travailler ensemble les
groupements d'artisans en essayant
d'optimiser l'offre de travaux de
performance énergétique ils ont réussi à
réduire les coûts de l'ordre de 20% par
rapport à la facture initiale que
comptait proposer les artisans donc il y
a déjà ça et après il y a des
dispositifs assez intéressants comme
énergie spring donc vous avez peut-être
déjà entendu parler qui justement vise à
industrialiser les travaux de rénovation
énergétique en la matière donc il y a
vraiment des des choses qui peuvent être
menées justement pour atténuer les enfin
l'augmentation voire même réduire les
coûts de la rénovation énergétique
pour les logements
c'est d'ailleurs enfin au passage ça
aurait été enfin notamment il y a eu des
le plan France 2030 qui vise justement à
proposer enfin des offres une offre
industrielle assez soutenue dans
plusieurs secteurs notamment dans le
secteur énergétique le secteur des
transports et une surprise que nous
avons eu c'est qu'il n'y avait pas de
justement visé qu'il y a rien qui visait
justement à développer une offre en
termes de rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments à industrialiser à financer
des investissements dans la recherche et
développement et c'est peut-être enfin
une opportunité me manquée ou un tir à
rectifier en tout cas pour pour la suite
en tout cas c'est vraiment un besoin en
tout cas de soutenir justement le la
filière et de faire en sorte que
finalement on arrive à réduire les coûts
dans le temps long vu que le volume de
d'investissement qu'on doit engager
d'ici 2050
si vous avez évoqué le notamment
l'actualisation qui est effectivement un
des paramètres importants on en a pas
beaucoup parlé mais du coup
l'actualisation qui finalement
des grèves dans le temps les économies
d'énergie finalement plus le plus les
économies d'élargir arrive tard dans la
vie d'un projet et moi elles sont
intéressantes d'un point de vue
d'aménage et ça joue effectivement
énormément sur sur les calculs de
rentabilité notamment parce que pour
modéliser un peu la version des ménages
à se lancer dans ces projets là on
actualise assez fortement les économies
d'énergie de l'ordre de 5% pour les
ménages aux revenus les plus élevés
jusqu'à 15% pour les ménages revenus les
plus modestes par ce 15% en fait on
exprime le fait que les ménages qui ont
les revenus les plus faibles sont
d'autant plus averses à se lancer dans
des projets de rénovation énergétique si
il perçoivent pas des économies
d'énergie très rapidement finalement
plus elles arrivent tard et moins ça va
les intéresser notamment à travers leur
préférence pour le présent
[Musique]
c'est une très bonne question
on appelle étudier la question sur du
point de vue des prêteurs
malheureusement en fait
à travers notre étude en fait on s'est
concentré sur le point de vue déménage
mais en effet la question du point de
vue des prêteurs se pose aussi en fait
ce qu'on voit en tout cas à travers la
question de la rénovation énergétique
c'est qu'il y a un manque d'alignement
entre les taux d'actualisation par
rapport à la collectivité enfin
nationale et par rapport aux acteurs
privés qui sont engagés donc les ménages
mais aussi les acteurs bancaires
les professionnels de travaux donc c'est
ça c'est là où en fait de toute façon il
y aura besoin d'un mode d'intervention
publique et lequel voilà je sais pas
ensuite vous avez posé une question sur
le La question de l'ambition des
objectifs de 2050 savoir si l'ambition
était réalisable faisable
j'ai pas envie que vous reteniez une
idée comme quoi nous nous pensons pas
que ce soit faisable en tout cas c'est
faisable sur le plan
énergique carbone technique enfin du
fait que
je vais vous le poser la question
différemment est-ce que vous pensez que
que la question de cette faisabilité
doit faire l'objet d'une réflexion et
d'études au moment où on parle là sans
trop tarder
moi je crois que oui parce que au fur et
à mesure des auditions on s'aperçoit que
en étant engagé dans un truc qui nous
débordent largement quoi pour dire les
choses donc voilà c'est c'était le sens
de ma question c'est pas pour vous
embêter mettre la pression
[Musique]
c'est une très bonne question moi je
pense que ça doit être justement traiter
dans le cas des travaux de la stratégie
française énergique climat enfin de
savoir
bien sûr enfin c'est vraiment la
question de la programmation si vous
avez une stratégie je veux savoir de
quel moyen vous avez effectivement
besoin pour voilà exactement pour
implémenter alors il y a des travaux qui
ont été déjà menés notamment de savoir
comment on peut avoir arriver à une
rénovation performante par étape donc
sur plan technique donc on sait comment
faire après sur le plan organisationnel
des aides financières il y a encore du
travail à faire avant la matière et en
tout cas enfin si vous décidez
d'abandonner l'objectif de rénovation
BBC fin d'arriver un parc à niveau moyen
BBC vous allez reporter les exigences de
réduction des consommations d'énergie ou
bien même de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre sur d'autres
secteurs ou bien vous allez viser une
production d'énergie supplémentaire en
France mais c'est aussi des enfin c'est
aussi un coup c'est c'est une question
c'est un vrai sujet à étudier
oui bien sûr oui tout à fait
tout à fait c'est pour ça que
non non en fait on peut pas définir une
stratégie pour les bâtiments indépoque
des stratégies en fait ça c'est tout à
fait
c'est ce dont conscience en tout cas le
s.gpe dans le cas de ces travaux ou bien
même la DGC clairement enfin si on fait
bouger un curseur ça a forcément des
implications sur d'autres secteurs donc
c'est très difficile en fait de définir
une stratégie ça dépend beaucoup donc
des autres secteurs
voilà des autres stratégies pour les
autres secteurs après en termes de
recommandations politiques je vais
toujours arriver sur le même point c'est
le besoin d'une programmation
c'est clairement enfin
on n'a pas toutes les clés en main nous
pour établir ce qu'il faudrait faire en
terme de politique publique en tout cas
montrer la voix à toute enfin que ce
soit aux particuliers enfin au ménage à
la filière du bâtiment de montrer où
est-ce qu'on où est-ce qu'on les attend
en quelque sorte et de proposer les
outils pour que ça s'implémente
effectivement en tant que tel donc c'est
vraiment enfin après la stratégie
française énergie climat il faut
directement engager des travaux à la
manière et cette question de
programmation des financements publics
pour le climat elle elle résout
également le paradoxe que qui fait
partie des questions que vous nous aviez
posé préalablement qui aujourd'hui
finalement d'un côté on préconise de
orienter les aides vers la rénovation
globale mais de l'autre on a
effectivement un besoin de constance des
aides à la rénovation qui est pointé par
de nombreux acteurs
l'idée c'est de ne pas perturber
finalement les ménages qui sont déjà
assaillis d'informations sur la
rénovation énergétique et finalement
cette idée de programmation des
financement climat c'est la bonne
manière de de réorienter en douceur donc
en faisant vivre pourquoi pas des
systèmes d'aide qui sont différents
pendant un temps pour les les
rénovations à gestes uniques et l'autre
pour la rénovation globale mais
finalement petit à petit avec un effet
de Vasse communicant de tendre vers ce
vers ce type de rénovation ça permettra
aussi à la filière de s'adapter plus
facilement de vraiment créer la l'offre
nécessaire qui aujourd'hui un peu
inexistante et à la demande aussi
d'anticiper et de comprendre finalement
que les objectifs c'est bien ceux de
rénovation globale et que c'est un
objectif qui existant comme tu disais
maximum précédemment que il passe
simplement un objectif assez BC qui est
déconnecté de la réalité
merci beaucoup à tous les deux c'est
très intéressant donc on a compris mais
on l'a vu aussi depuis un certain nombre
d'audition qu'il faut de la visibilité
la pérennité la stabilité pour
véritablement s'inscrire dans dans les
objectifs et dans cette stratégie
nationale bas carbone on vous remercie
on vous souhaite une bonne fin
d'après-midi merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup bonne soirée on aura le slide
qui a été diffusé oui ok merci